[Musik]
den hast du gleich zu lesen
malverbot berufsverbot essverbot trinken
ich habe dass die ausgedacht
mich haben sie beauftragt das malverbot
zu überwachen
es kann nicht immer klappen
nicht jede verfilmung eines großen oder
wichtigen buches kann gelingen
trotzdem ist es ziemlich bitter zu sehen
auf welche biedere weise die verfilmung
von deutschstunde von siegfried lenz
durch christian schwochow misslungen ist
es gibt zwei aspekte aus denen heraus
man diesen film betrachten kann der eine
ist ein mehr äußerlicher der andere ein
innerer und beide tragen zu der
enttäuschung beide dieser film bringt
der äußerliche gesichtspunkt ist der
fall e mail neue lenzens romanist 969
erschienen und schon damals war klar
dass die eine seiner beiden haupt
erwachsenen figuren in diesem film der
maler max ludwig jansen nach dem maler
emil nolde nach dem vorbild des
historischen malers emil nolde gebildet
war der damals noch obwohl man es auch
hätte besser wissen können als von
nationalsozialismus verfolgt da mit
berufsverbot belegt was auch stimmte und
ansonsten lupenrein oppositionelle
künstler galt die glauben das malen
gefährlich ist die glauben dass ich
gefährlich bin inzwischen weiß man dass
neue ein waschechter antisemit und bis
zum schluss überzeugter
nationalsozialist war und der film zeigt
davon gar nichts im gegenteil er tut so
als könnte man über dieses buch reden
und dieses buch zeigen umsetzen ohne
über neue zu sprechen und er entwirft
eine mahler figur die ganz anders ist
nämlich irgendwie flippiger heutiger
nonkonformistisch als selbst wenn sie
gezeichnet hat die meisten im gesetz
über die einziehung von erzeugnissen
entartete kunst teilen wir ihnen mit
dass alle bilder der letzten fünf jahre
beschlagnahmt werden
schon morgen
gewusst du singst hier mit uns und das
gewusst das ist der eine aspekt dieses
films der andere betrifft die art wie
die beiden erwachsenen und der joghurt
zwischen ihnen also der maler nannten
der dorfpolizist jepsen und sein
zehnjähriger sohn lisicki der die
eigentliche hauptfigur der erzählung ist
gezeichnet sind
so
der ist für die umrisse und dann kümmern
wir uns um die farben ins lenzens
geschichte und auch schon in der ersten
fernsehverfilmung von 1971 sind diese
beiden erwachsenen ziemlich ähnliche
sind jugendfreunde und sie haben
sozusagen äußerlich wenig
unterscheidungen außer dass der eine und
das ist der punkt des buches ein
verfolgter der reichs kunstkammer ist
und der andere derjenige der diese
verfolgung dieses verdikt durchführen
soll
eben das sogenannte malverbot
[Musik]
bei christian schwochow nun ist es so
dass man von anfang an sieht dass diese
beiden aber es ganz verschiedene welt
gestanden
der eine der korrekt in uniform
gekleidete nazi der andere der maler
gespielt von tobias moretti das geborene
opfer bisschen der oppositionelle der
verfolgte das heißt der film zeigt gar
nicht die verwandtschaft dieser beiden
erwachsenen die erst durch die
politischen ereignisse zerstört wird
unterbrochen wird und erst dadurch eine
situation herbeigeführt in der der junge
sich entscheiden muss zwischen beiden
wollen wir zusammenhalten
darf sie aber niemanden verraten
versprichst du mir ist und in dem er
diesen inneren konflikt dass jungen
sozusagen schon optisch auflöst lässt er
ihn gar nicht mehr zu und die ganze
spannung der geschichte verflüchtigt
sich
wir haben es also um es kurz zu sagen
doch wieder mit einem sehr typischen
ordentlichen gut aussehen und
spannungsarmen deutschen kostüm viel zu
tun und das ist vielleicht die
ernüchternde bilanz die man nach
deutschstunde ziehen kann
[Musik]